all right everybody let's get into the
friday mailbag you can email info
davidpakman.com
the emails will be reviewed they will be
screened they will be we're going to do
a lot we'll check them for bamboo fibers
the way that it was done in arizona
everything will be done it's crazy what
we do to these emails and then i will
read a few to you and respond we have
wacky ones we have productive ones we
have substantive we have people who are
just angry with me we have all of it all
right so let's just jump right into it
first one comes today from rick who says
about the trump conviction
rick says hi david i'm wondering why
lots of people are demanding a trump
criminal conviction nobody talking about
something that seems obvious to me any
jury is statistically bound to have at
least one trump supporter in it if not
more one is all you need for a hung jury
so it's all for nothing he would never
be convicted of anything in a jury trial
what is your take richard in california
yes i have said before not only is there
uh a political question here not only is
there a question of there's so many
different issues with the idea of a
trump trial a trump criminal trial
but
how do you even get a fair jury and
we've been talking about last week this
week in the context of the kyle
rittenhouse trial and i told my story
from my jury duty experience on
something very minor compared to this
um about how hard it is to get competent
juries even for minor things
i don't know how you get a real
a jury to truly do what they are
supposed to do
when it comes to a criminal trial with
someone like donald trump but i think
it's a merely academic question as i've
said before i just don't think it's
going to happen and i know people get
mad and say david you're making it less
likely that there will be a conviction
when you say that no i don't think that
that's the case at all
uh but or that they're less likely there
will even be charges i just don't think
it's going to happen all right next one
is from ren
ren says i have jumped ship
pacman's msm mean i guess they mean
pacman's mainstream media narrative
stance on bs vaccines has put me totally
off well to you i say good sir
bye bye
if you don't want to watch this show or
listen to this show
because of my view on vaccination
we probably weren't meant for each other
this was probably a relationship
that you know let's go with it's not you
it's me it's not let's let's go with
that
um also another love letter this one's
more more uh insidious this one's from
alex alex says
why won't you address
jewish supremacy i saw the title i said
uh-oh
uh alex writes this is really ugly stuff
by the way you may want to get the kids
out of the room alex writes
you want to call out white supremacy
fine do it
but what about jewish supremacy is it
because you were jewish and a supporter
i am not anti-semitic
at all
but if you seriously think we're not on
to what's really going on here
and who's really in charge of this
globalist plot
then you're wildly mistaken
at least trump tried to fight these
globalist internationalists i should
actually be using the alex jones
globalist internationalist trotskyite
socialist shun like obama trudeau macron
and the rest of these zio beasts
um
this is anti-semitic this is
anti-semitic and as i've told you before
i mean listen at this point
we i've explained this six ways from
sunday folks
coveted conspiracies are drenched in
anti-semitism
the whole concept of um
one world or shadow government that
there's a real government it's drenched
in anti-semitism it's just slathered
it's bathed it's sous-vided in
anti-semitism um this is a perfect
example and i don't know if saying i'm
not anti-semitic but is even part of
part of the insanity here but that's a
very very sick person but sadly many
people hear that and they go that person
is not sick
that's their politics and i agree with
them and that's
it's a very very scary thing
paul wrote in paul says david is there
anything stopping president biden from
using an executive order to eliminate
the electoral college it hasn't been
needed since the invention of the
telegraph back in 1861 why do we still
use it allow our president to be elected
by popular vote by the people period
stop wasting taxpayers money on
gerrymandering i'm looking forward to
your response paul well so remember
gerrymandering is congressional
districts
within states
usually when we talk about the effect of
the electoral college on presidential we
don't use the term gerrymandering but i
agree with the sentiment completely the
electoral college should go i've
explained why time after time after time
however there is something stopping joe
biden from eliminating it by executive
order which is that you need i'm going i
i'm going by memory here
to get rid of the electoral college you
need i believe it is
three quarters of the states
to do
a constitutional convention
now is it and or or
two-thirds of the house and senate
listen
biden can't do it by himself is the
point that being said the most direct
path to eliminating the popular vote is
something called the
npvic the national popular vote
interstate compact and this doesn't
require anything done federally it only
requires
states to pledge
instead of giving our electoral votes to
whoever wins our state
we will give our electoral votes to
whoever wins the national popular vote
so for example oklahoma could say
no matter how oklahoma voters vote
if the democratic candidate wins the
popular vote we give our votes to that
candidate if the republican candidate
wins the national popular vote we will
give our votes that to that candidate
every state has the right to decide how
they will give
how they will apportion electoral votes
and once you get enough states in total
whose electoral votes combine to be at
least 270 you have effectively
eliminated the electoral college
okay
um
i don't know that that's going to happen
all right here's one i have to admit
this is one of the strangest emails i've
ever gotten
this is someone who is furious
that i mentioned that we post content to
instagram
jeff wrote to me too much david
too much david dear david
you're my favorite political show on
youtube
but if you think i'm going to spend my
time going from youtube
to instagram to tick-tock or whatever
other social media you're seriously
mistaken young man okay you didn't use
young man but it felt uh appropriate
you're a political commentator not my
life it's like you got stock in
instagram you want to drag people to it
for the hell of it and i would bet that
a lot of your viewers feel the same way
i do
i'll see what you post to youtube but as
for the rest i'm fine with missing it
jeff
i love it i love it and no no one has
ever it's just i sometimes offhandedly
say hey we're also posting stuff to
instagram check it out if you want if
you don't by no means
jeff i love
that you i'm turning this around to make
it a positive thing
you are putting a limit on how much time
you're going to spend consuming stuff on
social media i think it's fantastic
these platforms are uh habit-forming
these platforms can suck you in
i i love what you're doing jeff you know
what you tell me where your line is my
friend and it sounds like for you it's
youtube i love it all of full power to
you lawrence wrote to me and lauren said
obviously the election in virginia was
rigged
and um this was we i know who lawrence
is and this is satire and lauren is
lawrence is astutely pointing out
um
republicans the new thing is if you lose
you say it was rigged
they said uh many of them even before
the virginia election democrats are
already trying to rig it there was some
state senator we looked at the clip last
week we looked at it again on monday
state senator who said um uh they're
already ringing eight here's how they're
doing it glenn young won last tuesday
they never mentioned anything about
fraud or any rigging ever again and why
is that because it's not really about
rigging it's about if we win it's not
rigged and if we lose it is rigged
that's fundamentally the only thing that
it's about and lawrence is 110
correct let's go to our next voicemail
it's from barbara
barbara responded to the
not good results in new jersey and
virginia and in general last tuesday for
democrats by saying david if democrats
don't wake up about wokeness
we will continue to lose more please
read woke racism by john mcquarter
mcauliffe was a disaster when he did not
support parents the school anger will
only grow
if democrats don't wake up about
messaging you know what's funny about
this is mcauliffe really wasn't a
wokester candidate
um and
unfortunately barb
one i hope i can call you barb one of
the um
saddest parts of this election is
yunkan won
with lies about critical race theory
critical race theory is a framework
typically taught or utilized in college
in law school etc
um it's not taught now the counterpoint
that people are now coming up with is
well listen it doesn't matter if you
teach critical race theory
if teachers are
a if it's the world view of a teacher
even if they're just teaching geography
it's still going to destroy our kids
different argument and you got to prove
that you got to prove that because
critical race theory is just not being
taught to kids
in virginia and so unfortunately i am
not a wokester myself and i've been
critical of uh
elements of the left
um but uh this is this i i think this is
a little off here barbara unfortunately
drew rhoden with a comment on last
week's show
and said david you mentioned new jersey
being a bad sign because of the gap what
i meant by that was
the last new jersey gubernatorial was
like a massive win for the democrat and
this was like barely a win for the
democrat
drew says
it's not necessarily a bad sign because
new jersey voter participation is very
low in these elections and the democrats
have not held the gubernatorial seat in
two elections since 1976 so in my book
this is actually a win for democrats
because we broke a multi-decade trend
yes as i mentioned you can always find
some
way to characterize a situation where
it's less bad i think this is the best
the most optimistic interpretation which
is
typically after democrats win they then
lose they just they straight up lose so
rather than seeing it as oh man
democrats won by a lot and now they
barely won
we should see it as democrats won
normally they would lose if you go back
to 1976 and democrats won again
so that is valid that is valid and at a
certain point it sort of starts to get
into the the level of you guys have seen
these if any of you watch sports you
know that
technology and and statistics uh
and machine learning and all these
different things have made it so that in
almost any situation you can create a
statistic that seems meaningful in
sports like for example uh you know
um for games played
by
leo messi
in the southern hemisphere
between
december and march
when his team is leading going into the
second half he scores a goal 50 of the
time
and then we would be our heads are
spinning and we're saying but that wow
that's really interesting but is that is
that at all relevant i'm not even really
sure and then you can come up with that
sounds pretty good he's probably gonna
score a goal you can say you know for
night games played in latin america
uh he very rarely scores goals in the
second half when his team is when his
team is playing
you see the point we can interpret these
things and we have to find meaning in
the statistics we have to find meaning
in the statistics and ultimately the
results in 2022 are going to tell us
exactly how disastrous or not
last week's elections were for democrats
across the country
i hope that you will get instant access
to today's bonus show by signing up on
my website you can go to joinpackman.com
we really do depend on your support
we have a staff here
we have
you know all these different expenses
we do health care we do retirement we do
all these different things and uh i am
able to be a better employer in great
part thanks to people who value and
support the work that we do so grab a
subscription at joinpacman.com
and we will see you in mere moments on
today's bonus show